It's early morning in Kyiv... but there's
already a line-up at the passport office,
waiting for travel documents.
Anyone who wants to travel to the E-U without
a visa will need a biometric passport.
Olga Antonienko has been here since 7 o'clock.
"Where do I want to go?
Oh, I've got lots of plans.
My daughter might be going to Belgium next
year to study, and I'd like to visit her."
Negotiations have taken years - the EU had
concerns, including regarding security.
But in Strasbourg in mid-May, the last signature
was finally put in place and President Petro
Poroshenko could celebrate.
But not all Ukrainians will be able to take
advantage of this new freedom of movement.
"There are some problems with issuing travel
documents, especially biometric passports,
to the 1.7 million internally displaced people,
and the people living in the occupied zones."
The EU views this with some concern.
Their ambassador in Kyiv wants all agreements
connected with visa liberalization to be correctly fulfilled.
"This will not be an easy task because in
some areas now like the fight against corruption,
the rule of law – we know that there are
a number of people in Ukraine who do their
best to backtrack on what has been achieved.
And therefore it will be necessary for the
Ukrainian authorities to be extremely vigilant."
But there are other problems on Olga Antonienko's
mind... the new regulations mean she has to
carry 45 Euros in cash for every day she plans
to spend in the EU.
That's a lot of money - for a teacher earning
300 euro a month.
After eight hours waiting, Olga Antonienko
could finally file her application.
In three weeks her new passport will be ready.
"We've waited a long time for this!
Finally we Ukrainians are able to travel out
of the country!"
The Ukrainian foreign ministry also has reason
to celebrate... in their Soviet era headquarters.
The new visa regime was negotiated between
here and Brussels, as part of a much broader
agreement to ease trade barriers.
Now that, too, can come into force...
"Ukraine has passed two milestones on its
journey to Europe.
But the party mood is being weighed down by
the ongoing war in the east - and tensions with Russia.
The free movement of people between Russia
and Ukraine could soon be restricted.
Both Moscow and Kiev are threatening the other
with ending Visa-free travel."